la clamidia es la enfermedad o infección
bacteriana de transmisión sexual más
frecuente en todo el mundo es más
frecuente en las mujeres que en los
hombres los gérmenes que causan la
infección son unas bacterias diminutas
llamadas clamidia tracoma se puede
contraer clamidia de una persona
infectada durante las relaciones
sexuales vaginales anales u orales si
una mujer embarazada tiene clamidia
puede transmitírselo a su bebé Cuando
este se desplaza por el canal del parto
al
nacer en el organismo la infección
comienza cuando las bacterias se
adhieren a las células del tejido que
recubre muchas de las cavidades
corporales denominado epitelio
mucoso una vez adheridas las bacterias
comienzan a invadir este tejido dentro
de la célula las bacterias empiezan a
multiplicarse cuando escapan para
infectar otras células las bacterias
pueden dejar intacta la célula de la que
proceden o Esta puede destruirse al
liberarse las
bacterias la infección bacteriana hace
que las células inmunitarias del propio
organismo penetren en el
tejido esto inflama y daña el tejido
mientras las células inmunitarias
intentan eliminar la
infección por desgracia algunas de las
bacterias pueden evitar la destrucción
inmunitaria dentro de las
células
el principal riesgo de contraer clamidia
es mediante el sexo oral anal o vaginal
sin protección con una persona infectada
puede tener un riesgo elevado si ocurre
lo siguiente si es una persona
sexualmente activa y es una persona
joven especialmente una mujer joven si
no siempre utiliza preservativos durante
las relaciones sexuales si tiene más de
una pareja sexual o si es un hombre que
tiene sexo con hombres muchas personas
no presentan síntomas si se presentan
síntomas es posible que no no aparezcan
hasta varias semanas después de la
infección los síntomas que puede
presentar una mujer incluyen flujo
anormal de la vagina o del canal de
parto dolor al mantener relaciones
sexuales o sensación de ardor al orinar
un hombre puede tener síntomas similares
como una secreción anormal del pene una
sensación de ardor o picazón en la punta
del pene o una sensación de quemazón al
orinar tanto en hombres como en mujeres
la clamida también puede infectar el
recto que es la última parte del
intestino grueso los síntomas de
infección en el recto pueden incluir
dolor secreción anormal o sangrado Si no
se la trata la infección puede causar
enfermedad inflamatoria pélvica en las
mujeres esto significa que la infección
se ha extendido al útero y a las trompas
de falopio la enfermedad inflamatoria
pélvica puede provocar dolor en la
pelvis infertilidad que significa no
poder quedar embarazada o embarazo
ectópico es decir un embarazo que crece
fuera del útero normalmente en una de
las trompas de falopio este tipo de
embarazo no puede llegar a término si
una mujer da a luz mientras tiene
clamidia no tratada su bebé puede nacer
antes de tiempo tener una infección
ocular llamada conjuntivitis neonatal o
padecer neumonía tanto en hombres como
en mujeres la clamidia no tratada puede
causar artritis reactiva se trata de una
inflamación dolorosa de las
articulaciones como reacción a la
infección lo positivo Es que la clamidia
puede curarse con antibióticos como la
doxiciclina o la acitrom misina también
se le puede recetar un segundo
antibiótico como la cefriaxona para
tratar una posible infección por otra
enfermedad de transmisión sexual llamada
gonorrea las personas que padecen
clamidia suelen infectarse al mismo
tiempo con gonorrea Es importante saber
que es posible que el tratamiento no
repare los daños que la enfermedad ya
haya causado en el
organismo puede reducir el riesgo de
contraer clamidia si solo mantienes
relaciones sexuales con una pareja
estable que no tenga relaciones sexuales
con otras personas y que haya obtenido
un resultado negativo en la prueba de
detección de clamidia también reduce el
riesgo si practica sexo seguro lo que
significa tomar medidas antes y durante
las relaciones sexuales para evitar
contraer o propagar la clamidia por
ejemplo utilizar preservativos de forma
correcta cada vez que tiene relaciones
sexuales puede reducir el riesgo la
forma más confiable de evitar contraer
clamidia es practicar la abstinencia
esto significa no practicar sexo vaginal
anal ni oral para obtener más
información sobre la clamidia hable con
un profesional de la
salud